wir sprechen jetzt mit dem langjährigen
nato general hans lothar domröse der mit
uns verbunden ist schönen guten tag herr
domröse
leider sehr weit entfernt von dem stopp
des krieges von dem stopp der
kampfhandlungen aber wir wollen in dem
gespräch mal ein bisschen hoffnung
keimen lassen und mal ein paar szenarien
durchspielen wie das klappen könnte
halten sie es für möglich dass
geheimdienste möglicherweise putin
stoppen könnten neutralisieren könnten
das klingt mir zu sehen hat james bond
das halte ich für ausgeschlossen
man kann natürlich in diesen tagen gar
nichts ausschließen aber das ist keine
verfolgung würdige option es geht nicht
es gab diesen amerikanischen senator
lindsay graham der hat das geäußert beim
sender fox news ist das schon mit breite
debatte nehmen sie das irgendwo war in
sicherheitskreisen oder reagieren doch
die allermeisten so wie sie und sagen
dass es das ist die welt von james bond
das spielt in der realität tatsächlich
gar keine rolle nicht mehr der gedanken
kann er natürlich kenne ich solche
gedankengänge aber die war weiß ich ab
in das reich der fantasie ein widerstand
muss aus ihnen heraus kommen das volk
wählt sich eine regierung bekommt eine
regierung und muss damit irgendwie leben
unter diesen verlust auch so
das geht nicht mit dem geheimdienst das
ist unser dann szenario 2 wie groß sind
ihrer meinung nach die chancen dass
china ein einfluss auf putin auswirkt
dass die drängen vladimir putin dazu ja
abzulassen von den kampfhandlungen in
der ukraine
das halte ich für eine überlegenswerte
variante sie sind ja partner keine
verbündeten wiki anlässlich des baumes
von putin gesagt hat sie haben sie also
vorsichtig distanziert auch in der uno
vollversammlung haben sie nicht dagegen
gestimmt also wir wussten sondern nur
fünf ganoven staaten würden natürlich
weißrussland unsere zwei zu nennen sie
haben sie enthalten also hier sehe ich
eine gewisse möglichkeit die
chinesisch russische allianz ein weniger
aufzubrechen und wenn man diese
kriegsverbrecher bilder sie die
vertreibung von millionen von menschen
das elend was er über das land bringen
dann könnte ich mir vorstellen dass wir
sie ein großes original von sagt
vladimir stopp dass das ist meine große
hoffnung der westen wie wir leider
hinsehen mussten hat ja dort keinen
großen einfluss gesprächsweise
weiterzukommen szenario drei jahren
eingriff der nato jetzt ist ja völlig
klar die ukraine ist kein nato land also
rechtlich oder vertraglich ist das
völlig klar dass das nicht ansteht und
trotzdem friedrich merz hat das ja schon
so ein bisschen angedeutet am freitag er
hat gesagt es könnte aufgrund unserer ja
gemeinsam werte die wir teilen könnten
wir natürlich schon dazu kommen dass wir
sagen das ist ein angriff auf uns so der
sprach vor allen dingen diese worte im
angesichts des angriffs dort oder des
beschusses der russischen armee auf ein
atomkraftwerk dort in der ukraine und er
sagte dann natürlich könne unter
bestimmten umständen das als
verteidigungsfall auch angesehen werden
halten sie das für realistisch
halte ich für nicht realistisch aber
natürlich wie eine krone politik sehen
wir auch hier im fortschreiten krieg
dass sich meinungen ändern und diese
brutalität diese
menschenverachtende vorgehensweise
verändert auch unser bewusstsein
schließlich steht die ukraine steht der
bürgermeister klitschko die wir gerade
gesehen haben oder der präsident
seelands die für unsere freiheit ein für
unsere demokratischen werte das ist
etwas wenn ich höre dass der israelische
bringen die band dort war dann erinnern
wir uns daran dass israel wenn es unter
feuer stand wir durch unser patriot
raketen geschützt wurden also es gibt
diese ausnahmesituation
hier ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht da
aber wenn er ist auch das schlimmste
treibt wenn er 40 millionen menschen
heimatlos markt wenn er alles
zertrümmert und zerschlägt da muss
irgendwann zwischen diesem extrem moment
und heute ein moment des überlegens
kommen und sagen stop it
dh dass wir einfach so zu schauen weil
ich meine da auf dem weg befinden wir
uns ja längst wenn wir beispielsweise
nach mario pohl
aktuell gucken eine stadt die quasi dem
erdboden gleichgemacht wird gerade die
sich von den fotos die von dort kommen
nicht mehr großen unterscheidet von
grosny oder aleppo das heißt wir
befinden sich auf dem weg auf dem weg
also wann wäre für sie persönlich der
zeitpunkt gekommen wo sie sagen das ist
jetzt auf der einen seite der nato
vertrag okay aber wir müssen auch
moralisch uns verhalten als bündnis und
dann eben doch dort aktiv einschreiten
also hier will ich den artikel 5 des
nato vertrages nicht als grundlage
nehmen sondern die un charta nicht wahr
und dann wäre es auch ehrende kohlisch
im auge die hier unterstützen denn es
ist ja keine verteidigung unseres
bündnisgebiet ist oder unser bündnis
befolgt um das scheint mir eindeutig
aber es ist die frage der menschlichkeit
der humanität die letztlich zwingen zu
handeln nicht heute aber vielleicht nur
mit wir werden darüber nachdenken müssen
ob er wie lange wir uns diese bilder und
dieses leid anschauen können wäre da
aber ein wenn sie so wollen un fall
letzte szenarien noch ganz kurz herr
domröse es soll eine neutrale zone
möglicherweise geben das ist so ein wort
vom wochenende darunter versteht
wladimir putin garantiert was anderes
als wir aber wenn man sich da einigen
könnte auch so eine neutrale zone in der
ukraine wäre das etwas was aus ihrer
sicht frieden bringen könnte
schwierig zu sagen im zuge der deutschen
einheit hat bundeskanzler kohl
seinerzeit die neutralität des
ostdeutschen gebieten abgelehnt hat es
gibt ein deutschland und das ist die
selbe zone insofern fällt es mir schwer
anzunehmen wenn man das beispiel
übertragen auf die ukraine dass die dort
andere regeln so nach dem motto
so lemberg ist neutral tief ist was
russisch oder oder sonst was tue ich mir
schwer aber wenn es dann ein ausweg wäre
dieses leid im sinne der humanitären
atempause einmal zu schaffen würde ich
diesen prüfen und empfehlen aber das
sage ich hier aus dem warmen im westen
diese entscheidung selbstverständlich
der ukrainische präsident mal der held
nach vögeln ich die werte der freiheit
und demokratie lebt herzlichen dank
normal oder anmerkungen anschließend
darf ja erweise sie hat dem vorspann von
der hochzeit durch ja das treibt mir
fast die tränen in die augen denn seine
eltern meine eltern haben 1944
geheiratet als deutschland in schutt und
asche lag sie sind glücklich und über 90
jahre geworden und das zeigt es gibt
auch im schlimmsten niedergang offensive
eine hoffnung das wünsche ich dem jungen
war das wünsche ich dem iranischen volk
und das wünsche ich dem ukrainischen
präsidenten
danke herr nato-general auch für die
persönlichen worte und zeigt das alles
heute die tränen in den augen uns allen
herzlichen dank
dann gesehen